SPEAKER 1: Hello.
I'm here with Shams, who is the
technical writer for Flutter
and the chief plushy officer.
Tell me, what are
the responsibilities
of the Chief Plushy Officer?
And how'd you get that title?
SHAMS ZAKHOUR: It was given
to me by another colleague.
I had some designs
for the mascot.
And I found a
company to make them.
And then we were making them
for Dart Conf 2018 in January.
I named her Dash because that
was the first code, the project
name for Dart.
SPEAKER 1: That's great.
And I think you have
some Dashes to show us.
SHAMS ZAKHOUR: I do.
Here is the first Dash.
And you can see she's got
some sort of turquoise,
light turquoise here and here.
After she was made, there were
tweaks to the Flutter logo,
where it was brought more in
line with material design.
And so the turquoise went away.
And so our second run has blue,
like a darker blue substituted
for the light color.
But is otherwise
essentially the same.
And then, I was requested
to make some puppets.
So I did.
I made a puppet.
Everything's a widget, you know?
So--
SPEAKER 1: Why is Dash a bird?
SHAMS ZAKHOUR: Oh, an early
O'Reilly book about Dart
on the cover had a hummingbird.
And it was a very angular,
spiky hummingbird.
But when the design company
that designed the Dart Conf
website for us, they made
this fat, round bird.
So also, I've had
Dash socks made.
And--
SPEAKER 1: Those are adorable.
SHAMS ZAKHOUR: And I've
had Dash fabrics made.
So here I have a chiffon I
plan to make into a scarf.
And then here I have
some knitted fabric
that I was going to make into
a top to wear at Flutter Live.
But people have suggested
that it should be
like a onesie, an adult onesie.
So I don't know.
I'll have to think about that.
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you so much, Shams.
It's been great
talking with you.
SHAMS ZAKHOUR: Thanks.
It's been fun
talking with you too.